(pensive music)
(paper rolling)
- There's been a major
shift in the war in Ukraine.
Kyiv has launched a counteroffensive
along the front lines to retake territory
and Russia has been getting
hit behind its own lines.
In Moscow, there have been
multiple aerial drone attacks.
In the border town of
Belgorod, violent incursions.
In Crimea, an attack on an oil depot.
And throughout Russia and
Russian-controlled territory,
there have been strikes
on refineries, railways
and all kinds of other infrastructure.
As Ukraine launches the counteroffensive
everyone's been talking about,
we mapped out some of the early signs
of its strategy and the
obstacles it has to overcome.
(pensive music)
Let's start on the front lines.
They stretch for some 600 miles
and experts say Ukraine
has begun to strike
in various places to probe for weaknesses.
Ukraine has already had some success
with Ukrainian troops raising flags
as they liberate towns in the east.
But Russia currently controls some 20%
of Ukraine's territory,
shaded in light red,
and Ukraine will have to push
through the huge trenches, minefields
and ditches that Russia has
built to defend that territory.
Adding to the challenges,
much of this land
is flat and open.
That makes Ukraine's troops
and equipment vulnerable to strikes,
especially since it
doesn't have the support
of aircraft to provide cover.
Plus, the destruction of this dam
in Kherson flooded a key
part of the battlefield.
Both sides blamed each other
but the destruction could
ultimately hurt Ukraine.
Not only has the flooding forced thousands
of people from their homes,
it makes it hard for Ukrainian
troops to cross this river,
which ultimately makes it harder for them
to sever the land bridge
between Russia and Crimea.
And it makes it easier
for Russia to move troops
and equipment to other
parts of the front lines.
Now let's look at the
attacks inside Russia
and Russian-controlled territory.
Hits on oil depots, railways
and other infrastructure are known
as shaping operations.
They show how Ukraine is trying
to choke Russia's supplies off
while simultaneously
attacking the front lines.
(rocket booming)
Ukraine staged similar attacks last year
using US-made HIMARS before
retaking key territory.
Now it's armed with British
Storm Shadow missiles
that are fired from aircraft,
which allow it to hit
targets even farther away.
That could force Russia
to push supplies further
from the fighting and complicate
its delivery of food, fuel
and ammo to troops.
In Belgorod, cross-border incursions
are forcing civilians to evacuate
and exposing gaps in Russia's defenses.
They've been carried out
by Russian fighters who oppose the Kremlin
and have ties to Kyiv.
That's led local officials
to call on Moscow
to send reinforcements.
Moving soldiers away
from these front lines
and into Russian territory
could ultimately weaken Russia's defenses
and help Ukraine try to
take back some of its land.
There have also been drone attacks
in Moscow over the Kremlin
and in wealthy suburbs.
No one has been killed, but
with buildings cordoned off,
windows shattered and drone
fragments in plain view,
these attacks have
shattered the perception
in Russia that the conflict is playing out
in some far away land.
Officials in Ukraine have
denied being behind them
but Russian president Vladimir
Putin has blamed Kyiv.
(Vladimir speaking in Russian)
- [Shelby] These attacks
undermine Putin's narrative
that the so-called
special military operation
is going as planned
and they've also fueled internal divisions
with the head of the
Wagner paramilitary group
lashing out at Russian defense officials.
(Yevgeny speaking in Russian)
- So how are these attacks
being viewed outside
of Russia and Ukraine?
So far, Western countries
like the US have continued
to funnel aid to Kyiv,
and if Ukraine shows
that it can use that
equipment effectively,
they could supply even more
powerful weapons down the road
(tank rumbling)
but they don't want a broader conflict.
- We have been very clear
with the Ukrainians privately,
we've certainly been clear publicly
that we do not support
attacks inside Russia.
- And there's another
important country watching all
of this closely.
China has signaled
that it does not want
to see Russia collapse
and Presidents Xi and Putin remain close.
So if it looks like Russia
can't stand on its own two feet,
experts say Beijing could
potentially be moved
to send lethal aid to Moscow,
which would mark a major
new phase of the war.
(dramatic music)